across southern europe
eyes are turning to the skies looking
for relief from a summer of scorching
fires
from italy where several regions are
ablaze
to the islands of greece enduring its
worst heat wave
in decades
in turkey residents use brushes and
buckets
to save their homes some are furious at
the government's lack of preparation
they burned us our lungs are burning
this is our future the future of our
children
the response is not enough it's
insufficient we need aerial support too
the state isn't helping without the
villagers it would be worse
there aren't enough firefighters planes
or helicopters
more aerial support is on the way from
the european union
volunteers have joined firefighters on
the front line
they've managed to extinguish most of
the fires on turkey's southern coast
where the flames have abated residents
are returning
to ruins
we are happy to have survived 10 to 15
of my trees have been burned
my properties are damaged the home i
live in is destroyed
there's nothing to do all my possessions
and money is gone
this year's fire season has been one of
the most destructive on record
according to eu data the extraordinary
summer
is testing the region's response to
increasingly extreme conditions
and we've got team coverage for you on
this with our dw correspondents on the
ground in turkey greece and
italy let's start with dw's yulia hahn
who joins us from
madagat one of the areas that has been
badly affected by the wildfires in
turkey julia what's the situation with
the fires there now
well the situation is devastating
firefighters here in the region continue
to battle the flames flames that have
left
nothing but destruction just look around
here
blackened tree trunks a grey landscape
and it looks like this
in many places here in the area we drove
around in our car last night
and we saw several forest areas burning
horrible images there was
thick yellow smoke which made it
difficult to breathe and now the turkish
authorities are trying to give the
impression it seems
that the crisis is under control to a
large extent but that is not what we're
witnessing
here on the ground according to data by
the european forest
information service there are three
times as many fires than usual this year
and more than one hundred thousand
hectares of forest land
have burned the eu julia has promised
turkey
water dropping planes and other forms of
assistance
has that helped arrived yet is it is it
making things better
well first of all the turkish government
has come under huge criticism for not
having been
well equipped enough to put out the
blazes when they erupted about
a week ago there were hardly any water
dropping
planes here in the country although this
region
is a region prone to wildfires this is
something
known now the number of firefighting
planes has increased
to 16 in total after help has arrived
here in turkey from
countries like russia and azerbaijan in
recent days a plane has also arrived
from croatia
yesterday and two more firefighting
planes are expected to arrive from spain
today
this has been as you mentioned organized
by the european union
5 000 firefighters some 5 000
firefighters are currently trying to get
the situation under control
but many people here in the area fear
that this won't be enough
julia thank you very much for now that
was our correspondent julia han
and monivat turkey
well temperatures are expected to peak
at 45 degrees celsius in some parts of
greece this week
the prime minister says the country is
experiencing its
worst heat wave since 1987.
greek authorities are advising
households and businesses to conserve
electricity especially during
afternoon and evening peak times
let's cross over to greece now uh
standing by is dw correspondent florian
schmitz in
thessaloniki florian it's been extremely
hot in greece how are people there
coping with it
the only way to cope with the heat is
actually to avoid it
of course people here in greece are used
to high temperatures especially
in july and august the peculiar the out
of the ordinary
is the duration of this heat wave
peaking around today with a temperatures
of about
46 degrees which is 114 degrees
fahrenheit the government advises people
to stay
inside drinks uh to drink lots of of
water
and to use the air conditioning not too
excessively though because
you must understand that greek buildings
many times are not well insulated i live
on the top floor of my building and my
apartment heats up to
cozy 38 degrees without my air
conditioning running 24 7. you can
imagine the drain on the already fragile
greek
power grid it's especially bad here in
the cities we don't have a lot of trees
a lot of
natural green so um the municipalities
keep buildings public buildings open for
people
who don't have access to climatized
housing but of course whoever can
escapes the cities to uh to go to the
beach and cool up there
so people are trying to stay cool to
what extent
is this extreme heat igniting a
political
discussion in greece florian
well for the time being people are very
busy with a dealing with the heat
basically but of course
we remember uh we see the the wildfires
and remember
remember the devastating fires in mati
in 2018
uh where more than 100 people lost their
lives so
especially environmental organizations
uh say that they've been warning
this and the previous governments to
take better precautions they say
we need better investments in heavy
machinery in
airplanes in in trucks and helicopters
uh we need better uh communication among
authorities
and we also need to invest more into the
maintenance of ford is
which means to um to pick up dry leaves
to to pick up
dry woods to uh prevent the fires
from spreading so quickly and also of
course to raise awareness to make people
um understand that barbecuing now
um and putting uh cigarette bumps in in
the forest can actually cost
lives florian thank you very much cw's
florian schmitz there in
thessaloniki
extreme weather has emergency services
on high alert in italy too
heavy rain and floods have hit the north
of the country
while wildfires are ravaging the south
the italian fire service says they've
carried out over 700
operations in the past 24 hours on
wildfires burning across the central
and southern parts of the country
let's bring in jacopo lentini here he's
a journalist
in palermo jacob where what is the
situation
like where you are in the south of the
country
first of all good morning thanks for
having me now
let me give you some number from the
15th of june until today
firefighter have responded to over 37
000 uh intervention uh
8 000 of which just in sicily which is
where i am i'm in palermo the main city
of
sicily uh now situation is looking a
little better than the weekend
where as you said uh there were about
800
um wildfires recorded all over the
country
now uh the city of catania um in the
eastern
region in the eastern of sicily has
shown some pretty bad images
uh the airport has been shut down for a
few hours over the weekend
the fire has rich bathing establishment
on the beach of catania and people were
forced to
evacuate so there's about
still um 11 or 10 11
active main wildfires sicilian
government has
requested the help of the national
government because it's unable to face
the issue with its own resources i'm
talking about about
30 30 to 40 additional
firefighters and civil protection
department squad
that have been sent from northern italy
regions
okay it sounds like it's a quite a
critical situation there
indeed uh jacopo lintini a journalist in
palermo
thank you very much
no words would you like me to provide
you with some more um
in-depth information thank you for now
thank you for now we'll come back to you
perhaps later thank you very much jacob
now let's try to put all this in context
we've got professor
moji latif a meteorologist at the
helmholtz center for ocean
research with this he's an author of
best-selling climate change
books including two hot times uh thank
you for being with us professor first of
all what do you make
of these extreme these multiple extreme
weather events that are happening
around the same time can you explain it
yeah i mean what we are seeing now is
that uh we are slowly leaving
the climatic comfort zone
um we have been in a relatively stable
climate for
many millennia however due to global
warming due to
anthropogenic so man-made global warming
we are
losing we are leaving this comfort zone
and
we are seeing extreme weather all around
the world
could be heat waves could be
extreme rainfall with
extreme flooding and you know there is a
kind of
unvisible hand and this is global
warming which
uh comes in different flavors and uh
yeah so we have warned uh for many years
uh that this can happen and now we are
seeing that it is happening
we've just been showing some images of
the fires have been raging
in southern europe of course there's
also been massive flooding
in europe and in china elsewhere as well
is
climate change happening faster
than expected
no not not really if we uh go
back 30 years ago when the first
simulations were made regarding the
influence of carbon dioxide
on the earth's climate then the climate
basically
followed what we have predicted uh
decades ago and so this is exactly what
we anticipated and we don't really see a
sign that we have
underestimated the climate
the climatic evolution it's right on
and unfortunately the political leaders
didn't really listen to our warnings and
this is now the consequences that we see
i wanted to ask you about that because
we're here in europe where the eu seems
to be trying to show some leadership in
tackling climate change but
this is a truly global challenge are the
eu
and governments around the world doing
what's necessary
to save the planet
no not really they put out
plans they define goals but they don't
act let me give you just one number
since 1990
the global carbon dioxide emissions
increased by 60 percent
six zero and uh
even this year 2021
we expect that carbon dioxide emissions
will rise again after the decline
last year due to the corona lockdown
and this shows that the
political leaders do not really
implement what is necessary and what is
necessary
our system systemic changes
okay so we have basically uh get away
worldwide from the fossil fuels
uh towards the renewable energies
and this is simply not happening fast
enough
and we have to work on this
professor latif thank you very much that
was professor moji blatif climate
scientist at the helmholtz center for
ocean research in
keel thank you you're welcome